- You need to go to the
doctor, like you just have
to go and get checked.
Because much like prostate
- It's quick.
- cancer which my dad had.
You should not die of
cervical cancer, it's curable,
and it is detectable and you just
need to go to the doctor.
- But the reason why
the rate is so alarming
with Ovarian and Cervical
cancer is because
you don't know you have it.
- Yeah.
- So by the time you know you have it,
you might be at stage four.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, so that's why it's so deadly.
- So go to, after this, call your doctor
- Call your doctor!
- Go get your checkup!
- Get in those stirrups ladies!
(audience clapping)
- I mean, I am so thankful
for my oncologist and
everything and he is such a wonderful,
good looking man and I'm always so sad
that's how I see him every six months.
(laughing)
Because I do, I have to
go every six months now,
that's my checkup, it is horrible,
and then you go and they
take your blood pressure,
and they're like your blood pressures up.
I'm like well no crap!
(laughing)
I'm like waiting to get this test done.
- Yeah.
- Yeah than I leave,
and I go eat a big fat
donut and I go shopping.
I'm like woo hoo!
- You deserve it at that point.
- Yes, eat a pizza!
(laughing)
- Oh my god I love pizza.